ils ont bien vu que j'étais toujours
vivant parce que on est à quoi à 100 m
c'est un perron il qu'ils ont devant la
mairie des papiers comme précisent les
cdc à mourir de rire non maurice
berthelon 82 ans n'est pas mort mais le
voilà obligé de le clamer haut et fort
la semaine dernière il a constaté le
rejet inhabituel de chèques et de
virements et pour cause le crédit mutuel
l'avait déclarée décédée
ils n'ont pas su m'expliquer ce qu'ils
aient dépassé l directeur me dit
maintenant c'est une question
d'informatique mais si l'informatique
est aussi rapide pour le décès il réduit
aussi rapide pour réintégrer dans
d'envoi dans ma vie actuelle quoi nous
tairons tout d'abord de vous présenter
nos sincères condoléances
la fausse information de son décès se
diffuse très vite
chaque jour des lettres lui parviennent
ces abonnements pour le téléphone la
télévision et le versement de ces
pensions tout s'arrête
plus grave encore sa petite fille qui il
avait envoyé un chèque s'offre une
grosse frayeur
elle reçoit un courrier de la caisse
d'epargne qu'elle avait émise miss
tchèque
pour cet anniversaire lui disant que que
monsieur leur père tenant dans son grand
père était décédé
alors elle me téléphone qu'est ce qui
arrive vous est décédé c'est pas
possible
ce que témoin juge alors s'ils tiennent
pas compte de ça c'est vraiment ce sont
des imbéciles
c'est une histoire de fous ici mais il
faut pas que ça arrive à tout le monde
parce que c'est quand même stressant la
banque a certes reconnu son erreur dans
un courrier succinct et maladroit
maurice berthelon clients depuis 25 ans
qui a déjà fait trois infarctus par le
passé espérait des excuses plus humaine
pour obtenir réparation il se dit prêt à
saisir l'agencé française des usagers
des banques
de son côté le crédit mutuel a refusé de
s'exprimer sur cette affaire